bonsoir on commence ce journal de
l'ukraine avec la visite du président du
parlement ukrainien aux scénarii le
président de la rada été reçus ce mardi
au sénat deux mois après l'intervention
de volodymyr zins qui devant les
parlementaires français l'entretien
entre les deux hommes a duré deux heures
il a porté sur les attaques russes sur
les négociations de paix ou encore sur
l'intégration de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne va votre coup venir un dvd
d'un sauna aux histoires de famille
s'était pas
rendu compte à gerland 3-0 dès
et en ce qui concerne l'union européenne
gérard larcher a affiché son soutien à
la candidature de l'ukraine une
candidature qui a été déposée au mois
d'avril et qui sera examiné les 23 et 24
juin prochains à l'occasion d'un sommet
européen shaw est presque aussi user
gérard larcher avaient passé leur
candidature et au kayak à propos d'un
homme qui accable de relance tardive
reprise qu'aux méthodes secrètes et des
attitudes tchernia
l'ukraine qui ont lettre de screen of
death à la littéraire métro-rer un des
conduits au pied de l'âne abuja cet
autre candidate à
l'union européenne
de crise ont vivement rejeté
une position claire - ya posé ses
absolue petit royaume sur montagne et le
président du sénat qui a aussi annoncé
qu'il allait se rendre à kiev pas de
date précise concernant ce déplacement
de gérard larcher ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'il devrait durer plusieurs jours
président de sonatrach se passionna
mairie de
cannes est une initiative de plus à
signaler pour les réfugiés d'ukrainiens
à lyon oui la ville continue de se
mobiliser un gymnase transformé en
centre d'hébergement a rouvert ses
portes cette semaine il s'agit du
gymnase bellecombe situé dans le 6e
arrondissement de la ville
belle couche aussi au khouzistan
depuis le début du conflit ce gymnase
qui compte 140 lits enregistré plus de
7000 nuitées au total la municipalité
lyonnaise a déployé 150 agents pour y
assurer l'accueil des réfugiés les
potiers trop conflict of school et
nastassja le climat restera difficile et
steven seconde mystérieux mobilisera de
stocker de cette passionnée qui
l'organisent atyrau beauté ce bijou et
puis à paris une initiative à la
destination des start-up ukrainienne oui
si vous venez d'arriver d'ukraine et que
vous travaillez pour une start up et
bien un poste de travail vous attend
apparaît une entreprise a décidé de
mettre à disposition ses locaux pour
accueillir les réfugiés qui bosse dans
la têt qu'il s'agit de l'entreprise
liberté living lab ses bureaux sont
situés en plein coeur de paris ils sont
mis à disposition à titre gratuit il
cherche une
liberté line lab et aux offices d'un
côté roots entre paris genève et y est
c'est parce que je tourne on termine
avec les élections législatives on vote
aussi en ukraine pour envoyer de députés
à l'assemblée nationale en france oui
les français qui vivent à l'étranger ont
voté la semaine dernière c'étaient les
cadets français de la 11e
circonscription circonscription qui
comprend notamment l'ukraine et la
russie en ukraine ils n'étaient que 33 à
kiev sur un peu plus de 400 inscrits a
effectivement avoir déposé un bulletin
dans l'urne je termine en disant m
accepter la députée c'est la députée
sortante elle est vraiment ensemble qui
est arrivé en tête anne gmt au deuxième
tour elle sera opposée aux candidats
communistes de la nuque dominique vidal
tac
france
il y en a eu aussi
par
dominique vidal leur candidat merci
beaucoup à tous merci